it was your great grandmother who got
you all involved in this how did she
fall into witchcraft I mean I believe it
was coming even before her because when
I when I was born she was already SE 70
years she died in
2019 she accepted Jesus and all of the
stuff she repented but we believe that
it was coming even before her that there
was like her her her family trying and
un raise her because she grew up doing
that she was like the the the wi in her
Village she was the shaman she was the
psychic she was the medion she was The
Exorcist even like people she used to
use um she used to heal people too so
she was like a big person in her Village
which make us think that it was coming
even before that we say four five who
knows maybe like it was even more than
that this could have been going back
Century for all you know
yeah so this was just accepted
if someone today in a suburb of New York
said okay I'm the village witch people
would look at that person well I don't
know actually these days maybe not 20 30
years ago people would look at that
person say you're totally crazy but this
this was just accepted as common place
and then your grandmother accepted it
and then your mother accepted it and you
accepted it
too but you drew a distinction between
white witchcraft and black witchcraft so
she did the and the white witchcraft is
supposed to be the more benign are
different types of Witchcraft and there
green black
red so the why witchcraft just to
explain super quick so witchcraft in
general is control and manipulation is
something that you do to get something
in in return so why witchcraft is the
type of Witchcraft that people use to
connect with n is they don't use that to
Herm they think that they are doing
things for good they are doing that type
of Witchcraft to help people super
connect with nature with the animals to
that that type of worship then you have
the green witchcraft which is the type
of witches that use um a lot of nature a
lot of hers kind of like remedies things
like that so you if you are a witch you
can be moving in in in a lot of
different things and then the the black
one is actually the one that's used to
harm people is the one that you used to
to control to kill to put to put courses
to destroy family to destroy a marriage
and uh so there are different on so my
great grandmother she used to move in a
few she used to move in green witchcraft
which is type of like the the healing
the the the herbs the Saints to heal she
used to move in white witchcraft too and
in Black I guess today we'd call someone
a witch doctor if they mixed up little
potions and but that's just that right
now now that's been supplanted by modern
medical science which I'm not convinced
has a better track record of bodily
healing than all the crazy witch doctors
of several centuries ago but that's a
discussion for another time so that that
you might call I don't know like an
alchemist or something like that mixing
different herbs and potions and things
but the the difference there is not just
you mixing and doing natural things I
think the difference there is that you
also call out to Spiritual Beings to to
to to come upon that thing that you are
doing and release that so I think the
difference is that witchcraft you use
Spirit guides familiar guides so what
whatever you are are doing you believe
that something is guiding that which
spirit is guiding what you are doing so
you you mentioned a familiar guide and
this is when I think of Witchcraft I
think of broomsticks I think of uh
crystal balls and I think of black cats
which had a black cat you had a black
cat I did but it wasn't because of
Witchcraft yeah it was all all nature is
but art unknown to
so the typically the way the black cats
are portrayed in witchcraft stories is
that they're the familiar familiar
spirits so what is the familiar spirit
so a familiar spirit is basically a
demon that is assigned to a family for
Generations so it can come for like four
or five generations so it's a it's a
it's a it's a spirit that at the time
especially like if you come from
generations of Witchcraft right is a
spirit that it will it comes to you
because of your ancestors so it's sound
one that helps you to do the I'm saying
this but it's not like that they are
demons they um they help you with the
rituals with the potions they kind of
also act as guide and also as protectors
so that's that's that's the thing and um
so when I did a ritual before my dad
died I was consecrated to this spirit
guide so he became my my spirit gu but
they can take the form of animals that's
why the blood cats but this is the thing
with people that I find really
interesting is that the concept of
witches and broom and sticks and blood
cats like it's not just that you even
have witches in government wit is like
you know ruling Nations and you don't
even realize so this concept of like no
witches right now are hiding behind nice
dresses behind you you know you are not
going to see a witch with a long nose
and saying I am a witch no cuz right now
they are ruling governments ruling
Nations through what they are doing
releasing those Spirits those demons
through the position that they have so
it's also important to to just make sure
that people come out of the mindset of
like that's not just witchcraft that you
see now in so in society what the enemy
is trying to do in Nations even here in
the USA through Witchcraft and we think
like this is normal no but I thought
Hillary lost the 2016 election so at
least we got a little respit for but but
you're saying that putting putting Miss
rodm Clinton aside for a second uh that
these
practices are being done by prominent
people and in fact speaking of Hillary
Clinton we know that because Hillary's
top campaign team invited a woman over
to have a spirit cooking dinner which
was just a witchcraft performance and
the the best excuse they had was that
this was a kind of performance art and
don't look too into it but it was
explicitly a witchcraft kind of ritual
do do you have evidence though that
there are people in governments around
the world that are actually doing this
stuff or is it just your interest no I
know that and even in my country now
like I live in in Colombia now last year
before the elections um when I was
praying for the new H the new president
and all of that like I found out that
the president in fact um the one that's
president now before the elections he
went to a tribe in Colombia and he got a
ritual done and the vice president right
now in Colombia she is a
wit did you find this out as a matter of
sort of private Revelation or you mean
like people were talking about it I was
thinking it and then it was all over the
news you saw the rituals that they were
doing this is my point he not hiding he
everywhere and he no hide they are just
doing it so you know like the enemy is
not hiding anymore the enemy is out
there you see movies TVs music you you
know recently we saw this concert at
Travis Travis Scott yeah yeah that was a
huge ritual that ritual I mean his the
stage looked like something out of Honus
B that was a
portal because it looked like a devil's
mouth or something and people were so so
that wasn't just a coincidence because
they tried to poooo all the criticism
and they said no no it was just you know
provocative imagery but the people that
you know people like me that we come
from that we knew that was a ritual
right there because I believe he got the
power through Satanism and through this
type of of things so for him to go to
the next level you have to do something
you have to do some sort of sacrifice
that was a huge thing right there that
he did the ENT the platform was a portal
the things that the the sounds that they
were playing when that was happening
there are really low sounds that open in
the spiritual realm portals of death and
portals for these demon wants to enter
so what was happening there it was a
sacrifice a human sacrifice people died
at this concer lots of people people
that don't know anything about the
spiritual they don't believe in in in in
God in nothing they said we felt that
something was putting our soul out of us
they felt that there was a weird
atmosphere so it's really interesting
that even people that are not spiritual
they were saying it felt like something
was pulling us out we felt suffocated we
couldn't breathe and I'm like because
you were part of a ritual in fact the
people that didn't die probably now were
cursed and have open portals in their in
their life because they were part of
something